[Applause]
the high representative I now give the
floor
to the president of the European
commission Rusev on the line
thank you very much Madam president
Daryl belter on hrvp my dear Joseph
honorable members
it's now almost a year ago on the night
of February 24th that Russia invaded
Ukraine and War was back to Europe
that night I think all of you remember
that our thoughts and I think also our
prayers went to our friends in Ukraine
I remember vividly how we followed the
news from the donbass and kief with
unbearable tension
and we all were wondering whether the
Ukrainian friends would be able to
withstand the onslaught of the Russian
Invaders
today we know yes they would
one year on Putin's perfidious plans
continue to be foiled by the brave
Ukrainian Nation
one year on Russia has completely
alienated itself from Europe
its most important economic relationship
and is isolated on the global stage
one year on this very Parliament last
week welcomed the president of Ukraine
volada mizalenski as a true hero he is
and one year on
poutine's Imperial fantasies have woken
up to oblique reality while Ukraine's
dreams of Freedom are stronger than ever
and they will prevail I'm deeply
convinced
honorable members what a difference one
year of unity
and resolve can make
in the early hours of February 24th when
Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine our
whole continent was holding its breath
some predicted that Ukraine would fall
in a matter of days
but instead the legendary bravery of the
Ukrainian people stunned the world
their Fierce resistance at the gates of
Kiev
the civilians who stopped Russian tanks
in the south
the counteroffensive of Ukraine's armed
forces in Carson
we can never match the sacrifices and
The Bravery of the Ukrainian people
but what we can do is stand firmly by
their side and that's what we've done
from day one on and we will continue to
do that they can rely on us
and indeed a whole continent has
mobilized from the volunteers of the
Warsaw station you remember who welcomed
the ukrainians fleeing Putin's bombs
basically to all citizens and companies
who have cut their electricity demands
together with you
honorable members
we have focused on three main goals
first
to support Ukraine's resistance against
the inviver invader unwaveringly
second
to undermine Russia's War Machine
and third
to build Ukraine's European future
together
and these three strands of action have
guided us over the last year and will
continue to guide us in the months to
come
continue
economic Humanity
foreign
affair
s
visible
shakwa
says
foreign
Missouri
tradition commercial
the Nouveau control the expectation of
the technology
electronic utilization system armies
helicopter
the Drone foreign
[Applause]
house
is
foreign
foreign foreign
this is the first global
thus it so Comfort Jesus Landis
and this is
rebuilding Ukraine
and its progress on the path towards our
Union go hand in hand
you've heard it from president zielinski
in this very hemicycle
I've seen it with my colleague my
college and Kiev
I know it from the colleagues at the
commission that they confirm it every
single day
ukrainians are making tangible progress
despite the war despite fighting the
aggressor they know that the accession
to our Union is a merits-based process
they have passed legislative reforms
that others thought would take years
they are making this progress because
they are striving for Europe with all
their heart and soul
Ukraine as a nation defined not only
by its history
and Heritage
it is a nation defined by its dreams
and Europe is one of these dreams
so distinguished members
let's honor these dreams by standing up
for Ukraine for as long as it takes so
that one day
the representatives of the Ukrainian
people
will have their place in this very
hemicycle long live Europe slav are
Ukrainian